hello my name is Stephen Iranian from
Wolfram research my talk is about
mathematical functions and new
developments there about how functions
although make evaluator and about
classical mathematical functions good
afternoon my name is Tiana Canyon so and
I will today I will talk about
mathematical functions first I want to
thank the vendor for a presentation of
myself during his talk ok
what's new in Wolfram language 12.0 12.1
from the point of view of mathematical
functions so first direction is an
improvement of what we have of course
improvement of documentation pages 250
plus mathematical functions
documentation pages were updated first
focusing on the scope section in 12.0
and then basic examples section 12.1 we
can we can check just take a look on on
some of the functions for example let's
go to do something like logarithmic
function yeah and there is a bit health
section yeah basic examples are now are
similar for all the mathematical
functions including special functions
through grammatical functions with
others so there are examples like
complex plot 3d and others like the
newest newest pictures that we have a
larger yesiree this is ok ok and all the
basic parts for all the functions are
are are similar they are looking the
same and also the scope section is a
standard his eyes now so we have all the
oldest we have say standard features for
all the mathematical functions now so if
you will take a look on documentation
pages for this 250 plus functions you
will you will see that the same
structure for all the documentation
pages ok let's go back to this and the
second direction is the of course
development direction so what we here
have of course a very big developments
in asymptotics part
five new horn functions with their
primes
they have been implemented into 12.1 so
they will appear soon they are
documented they are tested in something
like this so there are in fact there are
ten functions five standing for their
home functions itself and five for their
primes and also we are now working on a
holonomic functions we are redesigning
the outdoors for the holonomic functions
and they will appear after and let's
let's talk about them okay over general
overview on mathematical functions so
the key idea that we are working with is
that most of the mathematical functions
are solutions of different differential
equations this is the case for the
elementary functions so we can just take
take a look on this yeah so differential
equations are generating as a solutions
some some functions based on relating
related functions of course the same
situation so we can just do so it and
for example this equation is generating
vessel gene vessel wave functions for
the orthogonal polynomials we have the
same situation so you can see the
solution of this differential equation
and the last one here for example hyper
geometric 1 F 1 and hermit function so
there are somehow connected with this
differential equation they are solving
this differential equation so okay sorry
there there is some problem with this
but okay the next set of functions is a
hyper geometric class of functions for
example 0 F 1 1 F 1 or 2 F 1 functions
yeah so the 0 0 F 1 function is the
solution of this differential equation
so if we'll write down this differential
equation you can find it in the in the
documentation page you will you will get
the solution in 0 F 1 high priority 0 of
1 functions however if you will not make
your a full simplification you will you
will receive the following so you use
the there is a connection between
hypergeometric functions and for example
Bessel Bessel functions yeah in fact
there are connections between all of the
all of these special functions and their
elementary functions for example
let's let's try to solve this equation
this is a equation with singular point
zero and infinity so in fact if you will
write down this all with this you will
receive hyper geometric unit like your
function but originally this is a
differential equation for hypergeometric
one F one function if you will take the
hypergeometric one F one function
directly substitute it into the equation
you will receive zero so let's check it
that really this this equation is solved
by hypergeometric one F one function
however we can also construct the
solution seen in other mathematical
functions about two f1 function ok so
here is the canonical equation of hyper
geometric function Gauss hyper geometric
function and there are two fundamental
solutions yeah the first one is a pure
hyper geometric function the second one
is hyper geometric function with some
pre factor so and the general remark
here is that hypergeometric functions
are very popular and they are really
well known in physics they are very well
used in physics and of course after
update of documentation pages you can
find a lot of examples of concrete
applications in the documentation pages
ok this is about hypergeometric
functions but there are also advanced
special functions for example multi
functions were major functions you can
these functions are solving the
following differential equation so you
can write down the this equation in its
algebraic form and solve it and this
these functions are important because of
because they are solving the Schrodinger
equation for periodic potentials so if
you'll write down the Schrodinger
equation and just this solve it you will
receive the following solution the next
set is about the spiritual functions so
there is a spheroidal equation that is a
rather popular equation and it's solved
by spheroidal PS and thyroid lqs
functions you can also construct an
other solution using spheroidal s1
two functions however these are the main
functions and espero needles are
connected with the Legendre functions so
we can see that if this third parameter
is zero then we were directly receiving
more simple simpler functions yeah okay
so and the last one is a llama equation
so there is an equation like this it's a
very hard equation so there are in in
the Wolfram language there are no
functions that are solving this equation
there weren't functions that were
solving this equation because now we'll
we have them and if you will dissolve
this equation you will receive an object
that's called differential root but
we'll talk about this later okay so
what's the idea of this overview there
are a lot of mathematical functions yeah
there there is a set of special
functions and we are working with them
from the point of view of generating
differential equations and here is what
we are doing now we are making the next
step so what's new in Wolfram language
12.1 this is the new step this is about
how functions okay so overview general
10 new horn functions yeah this is a new
step in the theory of special functions
I will explain it later point functions
are generalizing the hypergeometric
clash of functions directly also how
functions are much more general than the
spheroid all ones lemay functions say
matthew functions and hoenn functions
now are the idealizing popularity in
physics for example the theory of black
holes quantum physics and others so they
are there are important from the
physical point of view however we we are
implementing them only now okay so the
general horn equation is an equation of
this form it has four regular singular
points so 0 1 a and infinity the horn G
the function that we have implemented is
solving this equation and also we have
implemented the prime function for this
I will explain why we need a prime
function
for the case of hyper geometric function
functions the derivative of hyper
geometric function is a hyper geometric
function just a shifted arguments our
parameters
sorry parameters not argument for the
hoenn functions we have a different
situation the derivative derivative of a
point function is a function of another
class it's more more difficult function
and because of this we have implemented
the pair of functions how in G and when
G prime like for the spirit o spirit LPS
and asteroid LPS prime because the prime
functions are not are not the functions
of the same class so there is a plot of
hoenn function for some set of
parameters point function is okay sorry
the problem of template so let's take a
look on the hyper geometric equation
it's written down here this is the whole
equation and we can see that we are just
adding one more term here so adding one
more singularity and this is the say
this is what we are making our neck in
the next step we're just taking one more
term and trying to solve to solve the
equation yeah so of course the solutions
of hoenn equations equation they include
hypergeometric functions also how many
function is a generalization of a llama
equation so let's take a look on this so
this is a horn function this is a whole
equation sorry and this is the llama
equation M so when my equation is just a
specific specific specified a home phone
equation with specified parameters okay
what about Hong ji Soho ng is just the
first the simplest solution of this
equation the another second fundamental
solution is is written using also ho ng
functions let's take a look on a special
cases of how G I will make it bigger
okay so twelve one function itself is a
specific case of Hong ji so we can see
here that we are just specifying the
parameters of Hong ji and this is hyper
directed to at one function
there are two two possibilities also of
course I mean you can generalize other
other functions from the list of
mathematical functions also now we're
able to solve the lama equation in terms
of hi ng so this is the equation that
wasn't solved in Mathematica now we can
write down the solution the general
solution of this equation in terms of
Koenji and we'll work with it because
this is this is a full function I mean
complete function we can work with it we
can differentiate it we can substitute
some where M this is this is something
you know
and also about importance in in physics
for example this infinite potential it's
often hanji factor this is a new
potential in fact it was derived maybe
two years ago so here is the solution
fundamental solution is not the wave
functions is a fundamental solution and
in in terms of how G multiplied with
some very big per function for a factor
however if we substitute this node in
your equation will receive that it's
true really this this function is
solving the Schrodinger equation so this
is something new this is some some new
subject in in in mathematics this whole
Hoenn function Ong function and it can
be successfully applied to some physical
problems already now and because of this
we are working with very implementing
these functions okay
as for the hypergeometric functions we
have a one major function called hyper
geometric to f1 function and have
confluent forms of it this is the same
we have the same situation with the
hoenn functions so there is there is a
general hoin equation and our confluent
on equations that are generating
confluent own functions so they are
written here this is the general
equation with for regular singular
points 0 1 K and infinity and here are
the for confluent forms of hoenn
equation this is called confluent point
is double confluent point it has to
irregular singular points located at 0
and infinity this is called big
confluent own equation it has one
regular singular point at 0 & 1
irregular singular point at infinity
there is a last equation three confident
how an equation that has only one
irregular singular point sync in
infinity and this equation is a
generalization of earing equation for
example the structure is the same okay
let's take a look on them on this one so
okay that's the problem
okay here it is confident horn function
a confident own equation two functions
points in home ec prime standing for the
confident home function and it's
derivative this is some plot of it what
is it what home ec is generalizing the
following functions so it can generalize
twelve one function itself one f1 and
also met u function we have derived this
for most recently and so home ec is a
very important function from a
mathematical point of view because it's
it's a very good generalization of all
the hypergeometric class of functions
plus advanced special functions also
Point C is able to solve the spheroidal
equation in general form so there is a
spheroidal equation and there is a
parameter lambda that that if we will
choose it to be spherical
agen value then this equation will be
solved in spheroidal functions for those
PS or q s but what if lambda is
arbitrary and in this case we are able
to solve it using hyn c functions and
work with it of course so Hong C is
rather important because it's say that
it has the biggest potential in the
hoenn functions I think the double
confluent function is much more
difficult because it has only irregular
I mean the set of singular points is
irregular zero and infinity and because
of this where we don't know what to do
with this function I mean in in general
how to construct the solutions good
solutions in this singular points
because it's impossible however we
implemented two functions for Indian xx
prime
that are solving this I could I mean the
whole point is solving this equation P
confident Hoyne function is a Hornby
function that solves this equation it is
its it general as the 1 f 1 function 0 F
1 function and its and of course
connected with the Bessel functions so
point B is rather useful in quantum
mechanics already at the moment because
there are a lot of articles on this how
can we solve different quantum
mechanical problems in terms of how B
function so for example if we're taking
EE an harmonic oscillator potential like
this let's plot it so this is a
potential like this we are able to
construct the rather simple solution in
terms of Hornby functions here it is and
we are able to verify that it's really
solving the Schrodinger equation
symbolically second example from quantum
mechanics is the following so there is a
set of class of potentials like this so
here here are here at the plot and we
are able to solve it using also home D
functions and here is the solution so
this is a rather say complex potential
however we are were able to solve it in
home functions okay and the last
confluent home function is called trick
of entering function it honty solves
this equation that has irregular
singular point at infinity this is a
generalization of Erie equation in fact
and of course how in T solves the
equation if we will just substitute this
coin T with space specified parameters
into area equation will receive a zero
of course okay this is point is imported
from both classical and quantum
mechanics point of view so we are able
to solve this type of equations in honty
so it's a classical and harmonic
oscillator it's often ha and we can we
can work with it we can simulate the
dynamics we are able to also solve some
solutions from quantum mechanics in fact
it's the same potential for
polynomial potential and we are able to
solve it in heinki functions yep and
also very surprising we have a very
surprising result that when we're
implementing these hoeing functions or
thinking that hoeing functions will be
the most important ones however we found
out one very beautiful example from
quantum mechanics how we can use also
prime functions so let me show this
example okay so there is a potential a
recent potential like this inverse
square root and surprisingly so it's a
singular potential like this and
surprisingly it's solved in honty prime
functions so this is a very original
result and this is showing why we that
that our implementation is is useful so
here is the solution the two fundamental
solutions and we are just substituting
and receiving a zero so I mean this
function this function this best
solutions are solving the equation and
this is a rather good result and in fact
you can find all these examples in the
documentation pages of Hoenn functions
because the documentation pages of Hoenn
functions are similar to all the other
mathematical function documentation
pages because we are now we have some
standards and we are making everything
to to be similar to this okay so this
was about Hoenn functions that will
appear in 12.1 soon what else what we
are working now at the moment so we are
working on a next step of theory of
special functions the general holonomic
evaluator at the moment we have two
functions differential route
indifference route in wall frame
language yeah differential route is a
function that you can use to define your
own special function so you are giving
just some differential equation some
initial points and values initial point
and values and differential rules is
able to numerically construct some
function that that is a solution of this
differential equation with this initial
time values okay
however at the moment differential route
is using not a very good scheme because
it's using n dissolve so this is it's
using numerical integration scheme but
it's not very good from the point of
view special functions because in
special functions theory
have a Frobenius theory that is able to
construct all the solutions in power
series so at the moment we are
implementing a new evaluation scheme for
differential route that will be based on
series expansions and analytic
continuation procedure in fact this is
done already a way of also updated
totally updated all the document I mean
documentation pages for differential
route indifference route with a very big
set of examples but they will not appear
in 12.1 they will occur two and two I
think
and the next step that we are now
working is our optimized algorithms for
this holonomic evaluators because series
based on a continuation scheme is good
but it's not very fast it's faster than
the current differential route however
it's not very it's not the optimal one
and because of this we are trying to now
implement this fast summation all droids
like rectangular splitting binaries
putting in others to the to the
differential route okay so this is all
on mathematical functions I like to make
just a small summary so in fact we have
updated fully updated documentation
pages for all the mathematical functions
250 plus functions 252 I think then we
have implemented 10 new hoenn functions
and also designed some examples how we
can use them like in physics here in
classical mechanics or quantum mechanics
and at the moment we are working on the
improvements of autonomic evaluators
this is all thank you for attention and
I'm ready to answer all the questions
you